[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i just like crazy people yeah and the
friend that i'm living in her house now
is really i had no idea when i met her a
few years ago that i would live in her
house i just liked her because she was
crazy yeah she's a psycho she's a psycho
now she acknowledges her psychosis right
she's like she knows she's nuts you know
yes
she's this is the first line this is one
of the first lines that came out of her
mouth which made me love her and i
thought was funny she looked at me very
earnestly over lunch and she said i feel
horrible for harvey weinstein
and as soon as she said that i go i'm
going to be friends with this woman
forever yeah probably i said this is a
person
i'm going to take a journey into their
life yeah because i that's to me to say
that earnestly you also feel bad for
harvey not
no i don't feel bad for him you're
bummed out
i think we could have worked together
right now is the time to make people
feel stupid and call people every day
and tell them something that you just
heard that they don't know and make them
feel like an idiot for not knowing it do
you find that the you know what's a you
got tested by the way you got tested at
the facility didn't you it's all fake i
mean rogan had his guy testing me but i
don't believe any of that's real you
don't no i think there's a lot of people
going around now being like yeah they're
about let me pick your [ __ ] well dude i
just let me prick your finger and yeah
you're all good by the way isn't it odd
that everyone that goes to rogan studios
negative yeah no every person's negative
are you a cosby denier do you feel like
what cosby did was uh
was any of that true or no
no it was true all of it was true a lot
of it yeah but i will tell you that
about michael
michael jackson yeah or jordan either
one
a lot of the michael jackson was i
believe true you think a lot of the kids
stuff was real yeah you think any of
that stuff was real did he [ __ ] kids
yeah yeah i don't know dude i got to
tell you what are you what let me know a
lot of conspiracies online about those
guys looking for money i i understand
that but i'm just going off of why a
grown man would sleep in an amusement
park
in his home okay and then sleep in a bed
with kids let's talk about it it's a bad
okay sign interview me you i'm i'm just
a man who lives that same life
i'm just a rich guy okay okay so we're a
little concerned uh we're from the
neighborhood
we're a little concerned about some of
the goings on i mean we do appreciate
the roller coaster we do like it yeah i
thought you liked it didn't you you know
we do enjoy it but a lot of the k you
know the kids are having long stays and
i mean it's not a camp technically so we
don't know what you're doing and well
did you do you know that we are doing
ice cream sandwiches tonight all through
the night we're making homemade ice
cream sandwiches really yeah
homemade like on cookies like chip
witches yeah we're cooked we're baking
the cookies organic baked cookies like
from scratch and then we're also making
our own ice cream interesting all right
and so you just sleep with the kids
well i mean we're up all night eating
popcorn and ice cream that's fine i mean
that's i don't know if they end up at
the bottom of my bed when i'm sleeping
yeah
we're it's a big it's a slumber party
well i got to be honest now that you've
explained it i don't have a huge issue i
just got to talk to my wife because you
know them
they're irrational i can't believe we
let them out of that they're irrational
i have an idea of i listen my practice
is western medicine but i understand
holistic health you do you do dabble in
eastern medicine that's the difference
between me and a lot of people is that i
know traditional medicine but i
understand the body
and that's what that's what i bring to
the table like a lot of people don't
that's why i i treat my body like a
temple i uh and i and i have come out
and said some controversial things that
people don't want to hear a lot of it a
lot like exercise will kill you you also
say you also say double vax there's
anti-vaxxers and you're a double vaxxer
which means get it twice i've i i've
said i've i've said there should be a
heroin vaccination right where everyone
should take a full needle intravenous
too of heroin but you've but you've been
cut but the controversy some people just
keep throwing up and they're like [ __ ]
it and some people are like whoo
but the article that came out of
newsweek that you got a lot of heat for
was because you said that we should all
share the the one needle for there
should be only three needles i said that
i said everyone should you know there
should be a needle for the wealthy that
they should share right middle class and
then poor and then the poor right but
you also know the controversy in
newsweek said that the poor needle would
be shared by exponentially more people
and your response to that was
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it yeah yeah and and what's
interesting about that
is that uh death has to be embraced as a
part of science oh yeah right i i
believe in death
a friend of mine was approached by kevin
spacey i've had a friend was approached
by kevin spacey too to go to sting's
house he was like do you want to go to
sting's house with me oh what do you
think happens there give me the picture
of what happens when you go to sting's
house with kevin spacey
i don't know i mean sting is uh i've
never heard anything about sting and
i've kind of really i've done episodes
on my podcast about human trafficking
and we've talked about celebrities sting
has never come up you know no no i
talked a lot more about politicians he
has legal sex he he's right he's getting
into like tantric sex loves tantric
stuff he loves tantric sex yes so he's
big into like going for hours and hours
and hours he's also when he's all good
looking guys talented he probably has a
little small penis he loves cocking too
right big cupcakes so so what is spacey
doing in that situation why i want you
to paint me the picture i don't know
yeah i mean i would give me the best
guess
hey tim welcome i'm sting's assistant
and i'm who am i now you're you you [ __ ]
oh hey tim welcome i'm sting's assistant
i'm margo do you want to go to the back
there by the pool um sure what's going
on back there is it is it uh is it like
a benihana night
no it it was yeah yeah that was what's
happening tonight is chili's we're doing
chili's night oh okay we have chili's
catered in and uh and there's there's
just some people to meet back there some
fun people yeah you want to remove your
clothes real quick um keep your shoes on
please keep your shoes on clothes off
shoes on okay we're like the opposite of
most homes most people make you take off
their shoes we say get your dick out but
leave your shoes on and and then just
whoever wants my dick gets it oh pretty
much yeah pretty much and we're not
super concerned about like making
everyone show their license no good yeah
why because right i don't even know if
you can everybody should just really
experience life how old are you uh
i'm 34. you're good yeah i mean you're a
little old but you're good yeah we'll
take you i would like to think sting's
not [ __ ] kids no he doesn't [ __ ] kids
i hope he's not [ __ ] i don't think
spacey [ __ ] kids either i think he hits
on kids no i think he [ __ ] kids you do
well
he's hitting on them
what do you think maybe he's never
landed one how stupid are those kids
[Laughter]
420 means what to you nothing yeah same
i mean listen man no i hate that it's a
day most controversial opinion that i've
never said and i've said a lot of stuff
where people have been upset
i'm pro-eating dog i've said that i've
said eating a dog is much
more natural than putting it in a
stroller and pushing it down a street
and pretending it's your child yeah much
more natural
to eat it right pretend it's your baby
but you don't want to do it personally
you're just okay with it no i want to i
i wouldn't i would taste dog i'd be like
what breed do you think
oh it'd have to be something fatty
little bulldog yeah that's buffalo
bulldog
a blow job as a handshake were you
popular in high school
i guess yeah but like in a weird sense
like everybody knew me but i didn't i
didn't have uh my group was like three
people yeah so that's no that's okay
that's not that wouldn't be a popular
guy i don't know how to explain it i was
popular but that but would did you go to
popular parties were you i did popular
prom limo yeah i could if i wanted to
but here now okay but i chose time i
don't want to challenge you yeah but
this is starting to get very suspect
well you can't no no this whole idea of
like well i could have if i wanted to no
this is i mean let's be honest because
that's like me being like oh sure six
pack i could have one if i wanted to and
it's like
maybe i was maybe you could i i think i
was real
i just i'm trying to be a little humble
about it i won mr high school my senior
year did you yeah i was nominated for
homecoming king i didn't win they gave
to a kid whose mother died and the other
the other kid's father died 9 11.
so cheap so cheap i'm the real you have
to have a dead person i'm the real
winner my parents are still alive thank
you
my dad didn't die in a fake terrorist
attack that never happened
what are your main goals and aspirations
for for standards i would like to start
a small cult yeah where i would decide
who gets in
and what i get i mean
uh
i don't know you don't you don't need it
right you don't need it you've got a
wife and a home and you know i'm
surprised
yeah you don't need it no no i need i
need people who are willing to go out
and do things for me you know right yeah
like what some of the things that people
need to do for you punch elizabeth
warren if i want them to got it you know
if i said go and get her they get her
yeah i'm kidding that's a joke you know
i'm a comedian that's you know
it's a joke
one of my most controversial opinions
you say
weed's not for adults
yeah that's what i got a lot of flack
for weeds you'll never have more fun and
i tell people this all the time i smoke
weed from when i was 15 when i was 25.
you'll never have more fun
than when you're 16 years old you're
going through like a taco bell
drive-through or you're sitting at the
beach or you're doing something you're
smoking weed you're not supposed to be
no obviously guys like rogan that are
super [ __ ] like machines that can do
everything and accomplish everything no
matter what they do right great most
people aren't like that let's get real
uh it does affect your ambition it does
affect a lot of that [ __ ] yeah uh you're
not supposed to be a a pothead
in your 30s
it's unattractive yeah there's something
about it that's odd okay yeah
so here's my here's my i've been i
do you know me to smoke pot or no no
isn't that interesting yeah i use it
extremely sparingly but when i do use it
it's with shame yeah i feel bad about it
it's a shame yeah it should be
you should you should smoke pot my
bosses smoke pot my boss had mortgages
and i barely knew he goes yeah he goes i
take a hit sitting on my toilet at 11 30
at night and i go to sleep yeah where he
goes maybe i get baked on a saturday
when my kids aren't around and i'm
[ __ ] around in my yard see i like to
use it sparingly i like to use it at
night like it's with a with a drink or
something like that that is what i like
to do but here's here's what i like to
say that's i'm i'm not all the way in on
your side of it but i understand what
you mean i understand what you say well
it's because i don't i don't you're
cocking for big weed yeah i'm cut well
i'm a big weak
i'm part of big weeds i'm i'm part of
their prophet you know i parade around i
will advertise for weed and weed
products and i have yeah but i'm telling
you personally to be a pothead to make
it your identity to have it be a big
thing yeah it's never going to be as fun
you it all of this stuff now is what
this really is is
i never went to camp when i was a kid i
always regret it like i i it's a regret
oh and i wouldn't well yeah because i'm
like i never had that i never had that
no i always think about it like i never
had that experience other kids had i
didn't go to college i regret that
there's now adult summer camps for sick
people that want to recapture that
experience they never have there are
that's sick if you're 35 leave college
dummy it's over it's over so to me part
of the the weed thing is people being
like ooh i'm 30. right and i want to be
not or i want to do something that i
should have done when i was a child yeah
well here's what i think here's what
here's what i understand about what
you're saying
i've been i've been smoking pot since
i'm 15
or 14 or 15 is when i first tried it i'm
36 now and i went through waves of
college i did it because you did drugs
and that yeah but now that i smoke pot
it's like a very occasional thing that i
do to enjoy it
for something very specific i don't just
do it to do it right i never understood
just doing it doing it to me that'd be
like you know doing taking any drug
during the day or doing anything i'm an
addict so like people come at me and
they're like well you can't handle your
drugs that's where you don't like it i'm
like no i'm pro other addictions right
i'm pro being a drunk i'm pro get a real
addiction me be addicted to percocet fun
get a real be because this is what
you could be a 40 year old woman who's
crying a mascara off her face and
bashing a car in and on perks right
that's fine
but you don't be a pothead at [ __ ] 50
right like get a [ __ ] get an
addiction that's appropriate for your
age yeah you got to grow out of weed you
got to grow up like drinking looks
drinking publicly looks great
until you're about 25 and then it starts
looking great again at 50. yeah no well
yeah
it's the sexiest time the 30 40
is weird well to be in a bar when you're
in your mid 30 it's like alone
even with other people it's kind of like
it's it's almost not every now and then
but it's it's not as listen if i see a
guy who's really bombed when he's in his
30s at a bar like really going nuts yeah
getting into it i'm like what is wrong
with it what's going on what's going on
yeah what's this if i see a guy saw
pepper hair 50 years old knocking back a
[ __ ]
you know waiting for a second
arrangements date to get there perfect
just so he could power out in a hotel
and go on about his [ __ ] business
meeting life great
there's a time to do things and there's
a time to not do that so wheat is a
young drug young drug high school
college a little after that perfect and
then once you figure out your career put
it away for a little bit away
put it away let it go
that's what you pick up yeah maybe a
little booze little pills a little
cocaine every now and then i i i uh
a judicious use of cocaine but cocaine
has to have a limited lifespan because
if you get too far you become it has to
be judicious has to be judicious
judicious you're 27 little cooking yeah
when you crest 30 what about cocaine in
your 30 crest rough what kind of wealth
do you think you're going to acquire
i think i will die with 30 000 in the
bank
in total that's it in total yeah no i
would like to make real money like a lot
of money i'd like a lot of money what in
your what in your what in your brain
stem is a lot of money what goes that's
a lot of money i'm good if i look at my
career as a comedian and i say to myself
like a realistic projection of by the
end of my career what could i have if i
continue on my course yeah
six billion dollars easy six to seven
billion if i just keep podcasting we're
gonna go twice a week we'll do a patreon
if i keep that up i think six billion
dollars
[Music]
ain't no right way just the wrong way i
know
[Music]